these are Chinese medical workers
arriving at Wuhan Red Cross Hospital
with a patient suspected of infection
with a new corona virus the workers are
wearing personal protective equipment or
PPE designed to prevent exposure to
infectious materials infections and
deaths from the novel coronavirus have
continued to rise throughout China and
around the world according to the US
Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention how the new virus spreads
isn't completely understood here's the
protective equipment that health care
workers have worn during major outbreaks
such as SARS and Ebola and why it's
crucial in the battle against the novel
coronavirus epidemic PPE is used for a
variety of hazards in the healthcare
world one of the biggest hazards is
microbial and that could be viruses
bacteria fungi etc some are fine air
particles that enter your lungs some are
contact materials others can enter
through various orifices your nose or
eyes so when we're choosing PPE it's
very important to understand the
transmission coronavirus is likely
spread through a cough sneeze or other
contact with saliva but because much is
unknown about the virus healthcare
workers are following precautions to
prevent different types of exposure so
today when you look at personal
protective equipment for microbial risks
such as corona virus you're looking at
four items and they would be a face
shield followed by a respirator of some
sort followed by a disposable cover all
and finally gloves coveralls face
shields goggles and gloves protect
against hazards like Ebola that can
spread by direct contact with bodily
fluids the respirator prevents inhaling
droplets in the air from sneezes and
coughs healthcare workers wear
respirators while treating patients
during the SARS and MERS outbreak the
most sort of effective way of these
pathogens entering your body is through
the respiratory system so that's why
most PPE in healthcare settings tends of
folks around respiratory protection
protecting what comes into your lungs
the highly infectious nature of Ebola
led to the death of healthcare workers
in Africa
and exposed a potential fatal flaw in
the use of PPE we learned very quickly
that the sequence of taking off the
clothing was very critical we had people
making the mistake of taking off their
gloves and then taking off their
respirator or their eyeglasses or their
face shield and that simple mistake of
taking one off before the other
contaminated them and of course they
ended up with the disease the Ebola
epidemic prompted an update of PPE
guidelines by the w-h-o a global
shortage of masks has emerged as every
day people try to protect themselves
from the virus as you travel the streets
of any city especially in these days
you'll see a variety of respiratory
protection you'll see people wearing
bandanas you'll see people wearing
surgical masks you'll see people wearing
a very colorful masks that they buy
downtown while both respirators and
surgical masks are effective at
filtering out large droplets surgical
masks are less effective at filtering
out smaller droplets which can be
inhaled through the sides of the mask so
what we have here is an n95 respirator
it's 95 percent efficient at particles
down to 0.3 microns in diameter very
very small as reference your hair is 50
microns so this is 0.3 it's a fraction
of your hair as healthcare officials
look to contain the spread of the corona
virus they will rely on the availability
and proper use of PPE in impacted areas
the key to stopping this epidemic is a
combination of isolating those that are
infected and making sure no one gets
reinfected and the key for that
infection would be personal protective
equipment so it's not just about you
wearing the equipment to protect your
health it's also about stopping the
disease and in this case personal
protective equipment is really the vital
answer to stopping this epidemic from
spreading
[Music]